the M1 Ultra Max studio is Apple's most
powerful computer but with the launch of
the M2 Max MacBook Pros that could have
just changed at least for a lot of you
guys now in this video not only am I
going to compare the 3 500 MacBook to a
5 800 Mac Studio but also the four
thousand dollar model that is a lot more
attainable for most people we're gonna
take a look at a ton of different real
world tasks and see how this 3500
MacBook compares to desktop computers
that come with nothing but the computer
itself as you saw this MacBook only has
32 gigs of RAM that is half and even a
quarter compared to the M1 Ultras in
some of these programs do use Ram now
I'm going to start out with geekbench
six this has just been updated in terms
of single core performance the M2 Max
smashes the Ultras which were already
good but in terms of multiple 4 we have
15 200 compared to seventeen thousand
three hundred so barely any difference
now when we take a look at graphics
performance here the MacBook gets almost
000. now the four thousand dollar M1
Ultra with 48 cores hits 129
000. yes lower than the MacBook which is
crazy while having 48 cores compared to
38 but the full-on 64 core gets 153
000 higher but not by that much checking
out gfx bench for gaming performance you
would think that the MacBook would once
again beat out the Mac Studio but nope
we have 400 FPS compared to 416 and 485
so geekbench has a wide variety of
compute tasks where this is strictly
gaming now we also tested 3dmarks
Wildlife extreme and here the MacBook
gets 150 D1 FPS compared to 175 and then
212 so we have an even broader range so
if you're somebody that cares about
gaming well the Mac Studio is still
faster but I don't think there's a lot
of you guys out there switching over to
blender which is now using metal for
graphics performance the BMW scene takes
just 21 seconds on the MacBook looking
at the studios we have 37 seconds and 34
seconds how how is the MacBook beating
it out for such a tough task well these
new M2 series chips they have some major
fixes in the way the hardware is
designed that gives a lot more bandwidth
so unbelievably the 5 800 Mac Studio
gets beat out by a 3 500 laptop
switching over to party tug a lot harder
here once again the MacBook beats out
the other two and it could do so on
battery power on the go away from your
desk which is insane switching back to
the CPUs using cinebench the MacBook
scores 13
888 now I'm gonna pause it right here
because the M2 Pro in the Mac Mini
actually scores 14
757. now that just shows that the
MacBook is throttle down a bit even when
it's not thermal throttling now let me
show you the scores of the Mac Studios
they got 24
183 that right there is insane it's not
double the performance but we are
getting there and that just shows what
20 cores being clogged pretty decently
can do but now if you're not just
rendering objects with the CPU which you
wouldn't you would use Graphics let's
take a look at programming using xcode
our MacBook took just 69 seconds which
is insanely fast whereas the 500 more
expensive Mac Studio took 72 seconds and
then the same 69 seconds for a 5 800
model can you believe spending that much
money on a Mac Studio and it's just as
quick as a laptop and this MacBook is
super fast for daily tasks and a
speedometer 2.0 it scored 441 renders
per minute much faster than the Mac
Studio so it is quite nice now if you do
music production we tested out Logic Pro
with the New Logic Benchmark you guys
can check out the details and here the
MacBook could handle 181 tracks compared
to 315 and 341 for the Max studio now
this does have somewhat to do with the
amount of ram that we had but a lot more
with the CPU threads and stability so
that is still better if you're gonna
really push logic taking a look at photo
editing using Lightroom classic you
would think that the 20 core M1 Ultra
with way more RAM would beat out the
MacBook Pro but with our standard test
here the MacBook took only 39 seconds I
wish I had a Macbook like this when I
was doing professional wedding
photography the M1 Ultras took 45cm
seconds for both yes slower and they
have to be plugged in that is absolutely
crazy now looking at Photoshop I created
a high resolution HDR image here and the
MacBook took a minute and 20 seconds
come here to a minute and 22 on the Mac
Studios once again faster now how is
that possible well because we're
combining CPU we're combining the ram
the other changes that Apple has made
and it's just incredibly fast now a lot
of people buy MacBooks for that and
along with that video editing because of
Final Cut because it's so optimized so
taking a look at video editing using
Final Cut the MacBook took a minute and
15 seconds to export our five minute
hevc graded project that is very fast
now you think the Mac Studio having 48
Graphics cores or 64 and a lot of
everything else it'd be faster but no a
minute and 17 so it is actually two
seconds slower and the reason why is
because it's encoder limited and then
coders perform about the same now I also
tested this out in DaVinci Resolve which
is actually better optimizing Final Cut
now here the MacBook took 45 seconds
compared to 49. once again being faster
now these projects this is what most
people edit with it's very popular it's
compressed but what if you do something
a little bit tougher for example prores
raw to prores this five minute project
that was great it took just 43 seconds
on the MacBook 43 under 48 Cormac studio
and 41 on the ultra just being slightly
faster so because we have prores
decoders and encoders built in even a
Macbook could be just as fast and that
is absolutely insane now the next test
that I have is red AK Raw the radical
cannot use the prores encoders or
decoders so here the MacBook took 5
minutes and 40 seconds that is a lot
longer and this really pushes the system
every single part of it so you would
think that the better benchmarking and
Ultra would beat it out but in the case
of the 48 core that took 6 minutes and
40 seconds a whole minute longer which
is crazy I was not expecting this at all
now if we boost up the graphics now the
Hisense 5800r one is faster than the
MacBook but by barely it's a very small
difference and that it is just
unbelievable now the ram works really
well the other Hardware optimizations
just like we saw in blender really help
out with these high resolution files now
the last actual encode here is Canon AK
raw which we dubbed the extreme torture
test because it maxes out the CPU that
maxes out the graphics it pushes
everything to the extreme and here the
MacBook took 6 minutes and 41 seconds
with the M1 Ultras taking 547 and 534 so
here we are more CPU bound even though
both are maxed out and we do see a
difference but still very little now
that we have the M2 Max and it's just
incredible that you could do this
portably on the go unplugged from the
wall now we do have a difference in fan
noise and temperatures the Mac Studio
they have really killer coolers when we
took them apart on the M1 Max you have
the aluminum but the immunologists come
with copper heatsinks that are so heavy
and large and because of that they stay
silent all the time the MacBook in the
Canon 8K raw test the fans definitely
spin up it gets loud and it hits 103
degrees for the CPU and really hot for
the GPU wow the max studios are at 69
and 68 those stay silent and very cool
but with that the MacBook is still
barely behind the M1 Ultra Max Studios
now apart from the performance we also
have some other differences the Mac
Studio is 10 gigabit Ethernet which is
really nice to have and has six
Thunderbolt ports compared to three but
to be honest three has never been
limiting to me especially now that we
have magsafe for charging so you're not
using up one of those and we have an SD
card reader built in just like on the
Mac Studio and as far as Internet speeds
you don't have that either net plug but
the new M2 Max and M2 Pros support Wi-Fi
6E so I ended up upgrading my home
system and even without using Wi-Fi 6E
just Wi-Fi six the MacBook hit a
thousand one 162 megabit per second
compared to
741. keep in mind this is both on Wi-Fi
six the actual chipset in here is much
faster so even if you don't have 6E
you're going to notice a difference
which is really sweet and with that of
course the Mac Studio is a desktop so
for 3 500 compared to 4 000 or 5800 you
are also getting a keyboard a trackpad a
battery uh you're getting speakers
you're getting a webcam you're getting a
gorgeous mini LED really bright HDR
display whereas with the desktop those
are very expensive so the value that is
packed in here and being able to plug it
into a desktop monitor to use as a
desktop setup and being able to take it
on the go like right now when I'm
traveling it is absolutely amazing so
you guys let me know your thoughts would
you replace a desktop computer with a
notebook particularly a Macbook if you
have a Mac Studio or gonna hold off for
the Mac Pro whenever that comes out or
if you're gonna upload grade would you
want something that is Dual Purpose I
want to hear your guys's thoughts in the
comment section below go ahead and click
that Circle above to subscribe check out
one of those great videos right over
there and I'll see you in the next one
[Music]
foreign